wir gehen jetzt auch nach berlin denn
dort steht schon mein kollege erhard
scherfer bereit wir haben heute einen
wichtigen großen und proppenvollen tag
im bundestag vielleicht einmal ganz kurz
über die agenda gleich um neun steht die
bafög reform an das bafög soll jahr
erhöht werden am frühen nachmittag
erwarten wir eine aktuelle stunde zur
versorgungssicherheit im winter
natürlich ganz wichtiges thema und
später unter anderem dann gibt es auch
noch die einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses
zum afghanistan einsatz der bundeswehr
das alles vor dem hintergrund des
koalitionsausschusses der gestern abend
getagt hat und dazu hat mein kollege
erhard scherfer sich jetzt gäste
eingeladen ich gebe ab nach berlin
vielen dank claudia d ist ja die fragen
die auf dem tisch gelegen haben gestern
mutmaßlich beim koalitionsausschuss die
lage nicht nur da auf dem tisch sondern
die ligen ersten zwei tagen in der luft
und zu retten sauer auf der hand und
natürlich haben wir die situation dass
es gestern mal wieder keine erklärung
gegeben hat zu den gesprächen im
kanzleramt der 18er gruppe die da
zusammengekommen ist und beraten hat wie
es heißt bei dpa zwei stunden lang aber
wir haben natürlich eine gelegenheit hat
trotzdem vielleicht ein klein wenig
licht ins dunkel zu bringen so dunkel
ist es ja vielleicht auch gar nicht und
ich freue mich dass heute morgen bei uns
sind gesine lötzsch die stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion gehört und
wie ich dem koalitionsausschuss an was
sie gestern bei twitter schon bedauert
hat aber johannes vogel jetzt mitglied
im koalition immer am
koalitionsausschuss gewesen gestern auch
einen schönen guten morgen ja lass uns
noch mal ein bisschen teilhaben was
haben sie gemacht gestern zwei stunden
lang ich glaube man muss vielleicht erst
noch mal erklären was diese koalition
sich vorgenommen hat wie sie arbeiten
will im koalitionsausschuss im
unterschied ja auch zur groko vorher
werden wir glaube ich muss nun ganz so
kleine krisengespräche sondern auch
günstiger und situationen
krisengespräche und dann muss immer ein
statement oder ein beschluss und dann
sind die oft schlecht weil irgendwie mit
heißer nadel gestrickt dass es nicht
sondern dass wir gelegenheit haben uns
regelmäßig zur lage auszutauschen eben
auch auf der ebene in der sich die
koalition geschlossen wurde nämlich
nicht nur regierung und parlament auf
der anderen seite sollen parteien man
sitzt zusammen so und java und daraus
folgt dann ja irgendwann auch politik
also in den letzten wochen der
konditionstrainer gab es auch keine
beschlüsse oder statements und das ist
bekannt wir haben natürlich über die
lage in der ukraine geredet und daraus
ist dann auch politik gefolgt nämlich
die politik veränderung dass jetzt
endlich schwere waffen hinkommen ich
finde müssen schneller und genau so
haben wir über die lage durch die
energiekrise und der inflation geredet
und was der nächste schritt das ist ja
sogar öffentlich wird die konzertierte
aktion geben es wird ein gespräch geben
zwischen regierung die von uns getragen
wird hier im parlament und arbeitgebern
und gewerkschaften was jetzt nächste
schritte seien müssen die man der
situation auf die situation gemeinsam
reagiert und entlastungen notwendige
entlastung die bürger leiden da sehr
haben wir ja auch schon beschlossen
treten viele erst in den nächsten wochen
und monaten in kraft gottseidank und
trotzdem sagen und wird frau
wahrscheinlich auch weil es gerade sagen
es sind gerade in diesem end
leistungsbereich angesichts der sich
verschärfenden situation denn die
wird sich ja nicht verbessern selbst ihr
parteivorsitzender und
bundesfinanzminister hat von währungs
reichen jahren gesprochen das heißt man
ist ja absehbar dass die lage nicht
besser wird und dass die entlassungs
pakete die sie beschlossen haben so gut
sie sein mögen auch wenn sie teilweise
kritisiert werden werden nicht reichen
zollitsch hätten sie gestern abend
sicherlich mehr erwartet ja natürlich
ich finde auch dass kollege vogel die
situation gerade schön redet wir haben
eine koalition die passt nicht zusammen
die funktioniert nach dem motto spd und
grüne machen schöne vorschläge und
können sich dann hinter der fdp
verstecken weil die fdp juli betrieben
immer schuldenbremse schuldenbremse ruft
und darum gab es keine ergebnisse und
wir sind ja in einer wirklich
krisenhaften situation und droht eine
weltwirtschaftskrise und dann zu sagen
wir machen mal langsam suppa gespräche
das finde ich nicht befriedigend und
auch nicht überzeugend unser
konzertierten aktion muss man ja sagen
und der separaten da ja aber trotzdem
wir sind ja hier im parlament vieles
könnten wir sofort im parlament
beschließen dazu brauchen wir nicht
extra gespräche zum beispiel würden wir
die bürgerinnen und bürger deutlich
entlasten wenn wir hier im parlament
sofort noch vor der sommerpause einen
bundesweiten bieten decker beschließen
und zum beispiel oder eine über gewinnen
steuer alles und dinge und diese
entlastungspaket die sind eher durch die
inflation aufgefressen und außerdem
partizipieren nicht alle davon ich will
noch mal diese zahl von christian
lindner auf dem lange entbehrungsreiche
jahre drei vier vielleicht fünf jahre
knappheit werden wir haben sagt er und
rechnet mit einer massiven
wirtschaftskrise deswegen jetzt auch
noch mal direkt an sie die frage trotz
der beschlossenen
entlastungspaket die sich ja erst
möglicherweise im herbst anfangen
auszuwirken geht die aber die lage ist
natürlich nur dramatisch andere als sie
also als die lage an ostern gewesen ist
und wir müssen nicht trotzdem jetzt auch
wieder was in gang setzen um das vorweg
tätig zu werden und auszugleichen die
lage ist sehr ernst und deshalb finde
ich es auch richtig dass wir als
gesellschaft offen darüber reden dass
wir eine durch putin ausgelöste ernster
lage haben die die politik nicht weg
hexen kann sondern wo wir gemeinsam
durchmüssen und wo wir gemeinsam
überlegen müssen wie kommen wir
bestmöglich dadurch und wir sind ja
nicht untätig also ganz konkret sind wir
in der situation dass zum beispiel
gaslieferungen aus russland
ich kenne ja eine partei die auch immer
wieder sich unklar gegenüber russland
und der klaren ansagen gegen putin
positioniert hier im parlament das höre
ich oft aus ihrer fraktion so sehr wir
uns als kollegen sicherlich auch
schätzen wer braten zum beispiel ganz
konkret diese woche wie wir jetzt auf
diese gast rocksong reagieren können
durch das hochfahren von ersatz
kraftwerken aber sind alles andere als
untätig das mal ganz klar so und richtig
ist dass wir die inflation sehr sehr
ernst nehmen müssen weil sie die
bürgerinnen und bürger in einer art und
weise belastet wie wir das seit jahren
nicht erlebt habe und deshalb bin mir
zwei dinge wichtig erstens viele
entlastungen kommen noch in den nächsten
wochen und sie müssen auch kommen jetzt
zum ersten siebten in einigen tagen
gehen die energiepreise runter weil die
eeg-umlage endlich wegfällt dann haben
wir die entlastung für menschen die
unsere unterstützung brauchen
transferempfänger die erst im juli hin
im herbst dann für die erwerbstätigen
alles notwendig und dann reden wir jetzt
und ich find das ist kein so gespräche
dass man sie gar zu abgetan reden wir
zwischen politik arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften wie man gut aufeinander
abgestimmt weil man es nicht gut
aufeinander abgestimmt nacht kann es
sein dass es sogar die krise verschärft
und die menschen nicht wirklich
entlastet jetzt nächste schritte angeht
und einige liegen auf der hand zum
beispiel im herbst müssen wir darüber
reden wie wird sich eigentlich die kalte
progression aus die den bürgerinnen und
bürgern die gerade kleine und mittlere
einkommen haben geradezu überschießen
noch kaufkraft wegfrisst da werden wir
sowieso ran müssen aber das abzustimmen
mit den taten dingen die die tarife an
machen weil den tarifabschlüssen das
doch absolut vernünftig dass gute
politik wird wäre jetzt auf meine
nachfrage gern ist irgendwie natürlich
verstehe ich dass viele punkte nötig
sind und dass sie auch relativ viele
forderungen stellen dass sie auch
möglicherweise andere klientel nochmal
nachvollziehbar und auch richtigerweise
im blick haben aber was ist falsch daran
wenn sich arbeitgeber und der
arbeitnehmer an mit dem kanzler und der
bundesregierung an einen tisch setzen
und gucken was können sie noch machen
mal gar nichts falsch aber ich muss
natürlich reagieren auf diese bemerkung
zu putin ich will mal sagen wenn
irgendjemand aus meiner partei einfluss
auf putin hätte würde es diesen krieg
nicht geben dass man in aller klarheit
zu sagen da gibt es überhaupt keine
doppeldeutigkeiten und wir sind der
auffassung dass dieser krieg sofort
beendet werden muss und als allererstes
erwarte ich von allen das für an einem
waffenstillstand gearbeitet wird im
parlament hier wird pausenlos diskutiert
über waffen welche waffen dann wird
darüber diskutiert ob die waffen richtig
beschrieben werden durch eine ministerin
die verantwortlich ist aber die
eigentliche frage ist und die hat ja
auch mit der wirtschaftskrise zu tun ist
doch die frage dass wir einen
waffenstillstand erreichen müssen
zweiter punkt ihre frage zur
konzertierten aktion oder der
zusammenarbeit zwischen regierungen
parteien
gewerkschaften natürlich ist das nötig
aber das darf natürlich nicht
vorgeschoben werden ich habe ja schon
beispiele genannt was wir sofort ja im
parlament beschließen könnten dazu
brauchen wir diese gespräche nicht die
sind wichtig aber wir dürfen auch nicht
den eindruck erwecken als hätten wir
eine lohn-preis-spirale ganz im
gegenteil die preiserhöhung die auch für
die energiekosten ja so schon vor dem
ukraine krieg sich abgezeichnet haben
die sind natürlich schon vorher da
gewesen also wir dürfen jetzt nicht den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
sagen ihr müsst zurückstecken ihr müsst
den gürtel enger schnallen sondern ganz
im gegenteil die brauchen sicherheit die
brauchen vernünftige löhne und darum war
es ja auch wichtig dass wir in der
vergangenen woche die mindestlohn die
mindestlohn erhöhung beschlossen haben
aber auch die ist eigentlich schon
angesichts der inflation nicht
ausreichend sind herr vogel die
arbeitgeber in der pflicht mit einer
einmalzahlung vielleicht oder mit
höheren löhnen insgesamt um das
auszugleichen ja natürlich die lager
müssen vor allem bei den unschuldigen
bei den unteren und mittleren einkommen
müssten vielleicht auch mal
unterscheiden weil irgend einer
bestimmten einkommen zu hören ist es war
auch nicht schön eigentlich aber
natürlich wesentlich undramatischer als
für die für die unteren
einkommensschichten also erstmal für die
ökonomischen feinschmecker ja wir haben
aktuell keine lohn preis spirale wir
müssen aber auch darauf achten dass das
so bleibt und deshalb ist richtig klug
zu schauen das was passiert weil sonst
haben die menschen unterm strich keine
entlastung unseren stärker belastet als
sich wechselseitig verstärkt und
auffrisst und vereinfacht zusagen
zweitens ja natürlich müssen die
lohnabschlüsse auf die veränderte preis
situation reagieren es kann ja gar nicht
anders sein das erleben wir ja auch in
den tarifverhandlungen diese
konzertierte aktionen sollen ja gerade
keine tarifverhandlung sein da sollte
sich die politik auch nicht einmischen
aber ich bin mir ganz sicher und die die
letzten jahre und jahrzehnte bestärken
uns darin dass die in deutschland gut
funktioniert tarifautonomie dem gerecht
werden kann und wird aber eins weil sie
haben die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen angesprochen das muss ich dann
schon noch mal sagen eins muss man dann
auch mit einbeziehen wenn es darum geht
nämlich die rolle des staates gerade bei
denen gerade hier das ist ja das kalte
progression das klingt immer so
technisch was heißt dass das heißt es
gerade bei den kleinen und mittleren
einkommen die keine unterstützung der
solidargemeinschaft brauchen aber nicht
viel geld haben die schauen müssen dann
auch ganz normale familien aus der
mittelschicht dass gerade bei denen wenn
es dann eine lohnsteigerung gibt sie am
ende trotzdem weniger kaufkraft haben
sich weniger leisten können warum weil
der staat durch die konstruktion umso
stolzer dem es besonders heftig zu
greift dann hat man am ende ein
schlechtes sozusagen eine schlechte
balance erreicht weil die menschen
weniger sich leisten können das ist was
die kalte progression nennt und in
dieser rolle des staates bezeichnet und
diese rolle des staates muss man
natürlich auch an lassen sie uns auf
einen konkreten punkt kommen denen auch
ihre fraktionen hier heute im bundestag
einbringt nämlich die abschaffung der
mehrwertsteuer auf grundnahrungsmittel
der ist auch eine forderung des vdk
beispielsweise der hat sich der
angeschlossenen cem özdemir der
landwirtschaftsminister hat anfang juni
was ähnliches gefordert durchaus vdk
sagte abschaffung mehr wertstoffe obst
gemüse hülsenfrüchte die dürfen nicht
zum luxusgut werden begründen sie mal
ganz kurz warum nur für diesen bereich
weil man könnte ja lebensmittel
insgesamt auch im
natürlich muss mir auch realistische
schritte gehen und wir bieten ja mit
unserem antrag vielen die möglichkeit
sich uns anzuschließen das erste punkt
und wir haben ja gesehen dass die preise
auf nahrungsmittel sehr explodiert sind
und vor allen dingen auf
grundnahrungsmittel so was was zum
durchschnitt vieler gehört wenn sie sich
an ihren hackfleisch eiernudeln das ist
teurer geworden
aber zum beispiel kaviar und champagner
ist preiswerter geworden da ist doch
eine riesige schieflage und viele
menschen machen sich sorgen ich hatte
gestern eine schulklasse zu besuch die
haben gefragt erst fünfte klasse das ist
alles so teuer geworden können wir uns
noch was essen in zukunft also das kann
natürlich nur ein erster mutiger schritt
sein und das ist ja eine verbrauchsteuer
auf die grundnahrungsmittel und darum
laden wir natürlich heute alle ein
diesem antrag zuzustimmen haben sie das
gestern in der werbung gezogen die fdp
ist ja für steuersenkungen das wäre hier
eine beim tank rabatt haben sie es ja
auch schon mal gemacht also da wäre es
ja glaube ich vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen wichtiger absolut sind wir uns
glaube ich einig dass wir die menschen
entlasten müssen und in der tat bin ich
als freidemokrat immer der meinung man
muss eine steuer begründen und nicht
wenn man sagt eine steuer ist nicht mehr
gerechtfertigt wenn man muss
hinterfragen ob man sie eigentlich
braucht und die menschen entlasten kann
allerdings lernen wir ja auch sind wir
auch eine lernende gesellschaft und man
muss fairerweise sagen dass in
vergangenen wirtschaftskrisen gerade
auch in den letzten jahren
mehrwertsteuersenkung ausprobiert wurden
als instrument und die wissenschaft sagt
die haben ganz schlecht gewirkt die
haben nicht nur die bürger nicht entlang
ernst hat ja ganz kurz intervenieren
weil da ging es ja darum den konsum
insgesamt am laufen zu halten das in
diversen krisen irgendwie hier haben wir
eine andere situation hier geht es ja
tatsächlich um die um
lebensmittel ist ja noch mal eine andere
ist jetzt finde ich noch mal eine andere
herangehensweise ist irgendwie vom thema
her es ist eine andere herangehensweise
weil wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
menschen sich lebensmittel leisten
können trotzdem muss ich doch ernst
nehmen wenn wir die ökonomen breit und
zwar nicht nur einzelne oder einzelne
richtungen sagen dass es vielleicht ein
instrument was sich einfach nicht
bewährt hat wo sie skepsis haben ob sie
funktioniert ob es sofort dann am ende
bei dem durch preiserhöhungen wieder
aufgefressen wird das muss ich schon
ernst nehmen also wir müssen schon immer
in der politik zwei dinge zwei dinge
unterscheiden erst machten sie beim tank
rabatt glaube ich weniger bedenken oder
das hat auch eine andere steuer da wird
ja
wir glauben die mengen besteuert also
was wir schaffen müssen ist das eine
thema ziel sind uns da einig an der
stelle bei der entlastung sind wir uns
einig und zweitens was ist das richtige
instrument zum einsatz aber machen sie
einen damit sich weiter nicht zu spät
wahrgenommen das ist richtig aber er hat
die mittelschicht muss entlastet werden
aber deutschland das immer noch ein
steuerparadies ein steuerflucht paradies
und die obersten die milliardäre und
millionäre die sind zu wenig belastet in
unserem land und da muss sich was ändern
zollitsch vielen dank johannes vogel
vielen dank heute morgen das war wieder
munter und einem austausch stehen wir
wie üblich noch hätten fortsetzen können
sie dürfen direkt jetzt auch weggehen
weil die sitzungen in wenigen sekunden
würde mal vermuten auch anfängt danke
ihnen für heute morgen bis zum nächsten
mal